esta mañana se ha sometido a votación y
adoptado el principio de organizar una
conferencia de Reconciliación nacional
inclusiva para Libia esta adopción
constituiría un paso excepcional en el
camino por la paz en el conflicto libio
sobre la gestión de la zona de libre
comercio y continental el presidente de
níger presentó su informe de momento no
hay fecha para la puesta en marcha de
este acuerdo pero según el secretario
general las cosas se van por buen camino
negociamos este acuerdo en menos de
cinco años en el resto del mundo los
acuerdos tardan una media de 12 13 o
incluso 15 años
Así que negociamos y concluimos este
primer paso en muy poco tiempo y para mí
eso es una victoria política